boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation super exciting episode today
talking about blockchain for social
justice who better to have on the show
than Daisy owes him talking to us mmm
thank you so much for joining us we have
this is a really important subject and
you're the perfect person director of
blockchain for social justice been
around a year now events curriculum
we're helping the underserved
underrepresented communities and
individuals become developers in the
blockchain space entrepreneurs in the
blockchain space crypto investors this
is all extremely important work so yes
yeah yeah exactly tell us like tell us
why you got into the space yeah so I'm
actually learned about Bitcoin in 2014
through my work studying and actually
working in like a social impact
investment alternative economies and I
was like this is a really this is really
powerful this is gonna really change the
way things work I didn't know that it
was gonna turn into all of this that we
see today with thousands of coins and
craziness with the SEC and then in 2016
I got reintroduced to the blockchain
technology in a whole different way I
started really looking at in terms of
how can we really bring this into our
communities so in 2017 actually started
hosting economic health fairs where we
would bring folks from marginalized
communities and to talk about like you
know credit and things like that but we
would also talk about blockchain and
crypto as a vehicle to end generational
poverty yep mm-hmm
yeah that's that's my gosh this is this
is the applications that we desperately
need the technology for as soon as
possible
yeah okay so let's let's take let's
start unpacking what you're talking
about so you know we're we're looking at
this industry a couple years ago and
we're like okay what is it gonna evolve
into and the one of the most pressing
spaces for it to evolve is to help the
underserved communities become crypto
investors this is this thing you get to
bypass an institutional investor you get
to bypass that
and that's huge in itself you know
invest into coins into companies into
for initial coin offerings all this cool
stuff so is that kind of a big part of
the pushes for people to realize that
that they can become blockchain
developers and be like way ahead of the
curve I would say the goal is four fold
one is of course to help underserved
communities become blockchain developers
because blockchain developers make at
least like two to three times more than
regular developers because they're in
such high demand and that's gonna be
like the next wave right and we already
know that there's an issue in terms of
um STEM education access in marginalized
communities second is to help these
communities invest in block cam and
crypto not to flush other people's
pockets but how can we use this as a
vehicle to in generational poverty and
to fund necessary infrastructure in our
communities and infrastructure that is
not bureaucratic corrupt and basically
corporate controlled another up yeah
right another objective is being able to
help entrepreneurs who are already doing
social impact work in these underserved
communities actually learn about
blockchain and actually how they can
develop their own blockchain and
implement it into what they're already
doing to streamline their work and
accelerate their impact and then also I
guess the last part is being able to
reposition blockchain technology as
Masatoshi Satoshi Nakamoto created in
order to sidestep some of the corruption
I'm in trauma and harm that we have seen
created by these mainstream institutions
and and what's been going on in the
industry is we have forgotten what this
technology was created for and it
overnight it turned into like AI cos and
spank chain crypto kitties okay that's
cute and at the same time there are
people who are dying and suffering and
this technology can really help me don't
forget
we didn't forget those people that
remembered what it's all about maybe
maybe not but that's a whole other
conversation for another day damn
okay there's there's rude those who are
really important mission points I'm so
happy that you're addressing all of
those so let's okay let's pick let's
pick these four now and let's see where
would we go with them
so ending a generational poverty okay
let's start there
tell us about generational poverty and
how this is helping end it
well basically what generational poverty
is when an individual basically states
poor from one generation to another they
don't really have an opportunity to pull
themselves out of their um class or
socioeconomic status because of outside
is systemic factors that were
deliberately generated in order to keep
some folks disadvantaged and other folks
at an advantage right and tell us about
some of the factors that keep people
advantage and disadvantage some of those
factors are deliberate lack of
investment in marginalized communities
deliberate policies that had a racial or
gender inequity undertone such as the
redlining
that created the suburbs right but
rocked black and brown people out of the
suburbs where there was better education
systems greater access to jobs better
access to food etc yeah there is the
system of mass incarceration that
deliberately sets up infrastructure for
people to basically enter that system
from a very young age there's the
educational inequality there's income
inequality there's hiring bias I mean
what it's slow
that feeling though you know just have
to I have to let it sit with me for a
moment it's it's [ __ ] real and its
raw and it's there and it's pervasive
and it's been holding people back from
their full potential yeah hasn't held
you back though has it now they're mr.
Salyer
yeah it's really important and you know
talking about you know people as
individuals and people ask communities
you know there's there there's of course
as an individual you there's different
like sovereign to used to that process
versus as a community but these will you
describe to make it seem so driven
towards community like that that it is a
whole community communal problem that it
is that it's an it's a it's an attention
that's paid into actually solving that
problem is is very it's not there it's
lacking and that's okay so we you listed
so many important things there okay now
how does applying like I totally see
like coming in to underserved
communities and teaching about how you
could have you basically leapfrog with
becoming a like a blockchain developer
that is huge that's a huge that's not
even like getting out of
intergenerational poverty that's like
leapfrogging way out of and that's hell
yeah that's a huge one that's a big one
and then also identifying crypto
investments for the families they'll
also find and that I'm following I'm
following the huge importance that and
then you were talking with
infrastructure projects as well I keep
keep on packing because I think we don't
talk about this enough on the show so if
you can give us more of an essence of
the of the generational poverty of the
infrastructure that's lacking and then
how blockchain is coming in and like
projects like yours coming in and
helping
Wow I think the thing about all of this
is we are basically being forced to look
at it dead in its face because of the
administration that we are under and
here in the Bay Area where we are you
see it once you step out of this door
the mass amounts of homelessness elders
families children sleeping on the
streets and that is not by accident or
coincidence right and the fact that the
more wealth that comes into San
Francisco the more how many people we
see on the streets there's a reason why
that happens right so in terms of
generational wealth poverty I kind of
explain what that is now how can
blockchain help this issue
blockchain is not the end-all be-all no
what is not however it can actually help
us level the playing field because like
I said there are systems deliver deliver
deliberately set up to create this
generational poverty to have people at a
disadvantage because folks don't know
that it's also a multi-billion dollar
market for other people to be poor
because you can make money on them if
you own a prison you can make money off
of them if you own a bank you can make
money off of them if you own a ticketing
you work for the city and you ticket
people you can make millions of dollars
off of poor people right so it is a
profitable business and what we see
blockchain being able to do is eliminate
some of those systems that are creating
this generational poverty in our
communities and looking at some of these
underserved communities as guinea pigs
and test subjects for their different
tools of oppression and also for their
revenue generating streams so when we're
talking about blockchain and how it can
help these communities it can help with
being able to create localized
infrastructure right and being able to
help us really capitalize on our
existing assets that we do have because
sometimes we look at marginalized
communities and be like everything's
wrong no there's some things that are
going right how can blockchain
technology help us amplify that right
and also to being able to help us bring
in the resources that we need in order
to fund our own infrastructure projects
because then what ends up happening is
what we call the nonprofit industrial
complex right that is there in place of
the social service system and the
look sector so when the private sector
comes in and they do their due diligence
which is the destruction and obstruction
the public sector which is the welfare
offices all of that they try to come in
and support they fail right and then who
ends up having to come in next is the
nonprofit industry and we all know that
they are kind of ran simultaneously by
the same players in many ways right
so philanthropy then creates more issues
in our community because we're like hey
we want to solve this issue okay in
order for you to solve it we need to see
you doing it this this is in this way
unfortunately the way that mainstream
philanthropy wants us to do it it's not
the way that it should be done and it up
causing more harm and trauma in the
community because one eye a ballute cost
we're really just having like band-aid
over it right so instead of me having
like a food bank okay why don't you
teach me how to create my own grocery
store why don't you teach me how to
actually clear my own farm community
garden instead of me going to the food
bank to get food that Tekel old and in
mechanics and healthy anyways right
that's just like an example and
blockchain technology can help us do
these things that's why I started the
blockchain for social justice because
it's critical that we create technology
to specifically address some of these
issues of marginalization okay so we
take you know we have some we have some
good images as well to you know to show
yeah good point good point okay let's
let's pull up some of the images from
the site because you kind of you also
have a pretty good way of explaining
this through some of the graphics that
you have
you know let's talk about her
organization here before us Jane know is
that yeah we have been talking about
before SJ we want to pull up the we pull
up the the girl that you had you know
yeah yeah pull up pull up one of the
first ones from the site yeah the
guiding principles accessibility equity
innovation and this stuff this is this
is actually really important because
having principles having values that you
build out your whole ideology on top of
is crucial so okay so here we have
accessibility equity and innovation so
we've been talking about this and the
importance of it is again is taking
these new technologies out to especially
underserved communities and creating
more of a system of equity and then also
all the brilliant innovation that has
yet to be unpacked from their minds and
into the world you tell us um anything
else about the principles that you think
that we should well let's unpack the
principles let's do it I'm rapid-fire so
when we're talking about accessibility
and that is making sure that folks
actually just have an understanding that
this technology exists and what it's
currently doing and how it's currently
you know impacting our world
that's the accessibility piece and also
creating the these events and the
different curriculum that we have to
basically streamline that accessibility
I'm gonna be centralized right play on
where it's decentralizes information
yeah the equity piece is the blockchain
space is really white male dominated and
dumb in well let's look at the global
industry it's heavily dominated like
white male dominated and heavily
dominated by Asian folks which bears are
just not an issue with that however we
know that the world is more than the
just those two groups of folks right we
know also too that when we're talking
about equity it's not about like us
being able to have the same thing it's
about the simple [ __ ] that hey you know
you were already at an advantage I'm
right I'm at a disadvantage how can we
create a system where we actually put
more love and care and support into
those at a disadvantage so they can be
at the same level at those who came with
that advantage right that's what equity
really
and that's what we're trying to create
with this technology right and then the
innovation pieces we know that diversity
creates innovation so by creating
diversity within the blockchain industry
we're actually able to have more
creative projects more use cases that
are really viable tokens that are
actually sustainable and not [ __ ] coins
right and conferences that are like
celebrating diversity and all kinds of
different people they're not where's
just like a few different type of people
and you get all kinds of like whatever
that you get just the same old stale
stuff same speakers same individuals
conference at the conference we have the
chance to make this different because
blockchain is technology right but you
know the technology sector has been the
way that it has been just very
professional incorporated you know blue
collar or whatnot with blockchain
technology we have the opportunity to
create a new type of tech industry yeah
and really central diversity yeah are
you going to tech inclusion next month
sponsored by Google have you heard of
that event oh yeah I'm actually gonna be
speaking there about blockchain for
social just oh that's fantastic I'm
trying to get on that gig actually you
know directing part also actually asked
me the other day I did that last year
and was very happy to be part of that so
I'm glad you're speaking there yeah
thank you that's good what is that again
so in case anybody tech inclusion what
is it
I forget 1713 1560
I'll get it no I'll remember I'll find
it right here do you know what it is
yeah it's October 15 through 17 okay 15
through 17 and so okay so yeah this is
this this point okay you you make it so
clear it's like how do we properly
figure out how to give resources to in
tools to those that are underserved and
help actualize their full potential into
the world so that's kind of this idea of
equity that I think so many people align
with and agree with it's just it can be
like masked by so many other things that
harm people's understanding about it so
I think when it's like explained that
way it makes more sense and I think
that's like one of the ultimate tests of
humanity is like trying to figure out
how to do that have ever have deep
empathy figure out how to funnel
resources and tools down and then help
people become their fullest and also
it's also like people that have some
sort of already like advantage
monetarily etc that well there are the
megalomaniacs that are trying to like
transcend and get away from everyone
that's poor and there's also other
people that do that exact process of
figuring out how to funnel resources and
like those are the real ones you know
yeah I don't know why that's so hard for
people to understand but you know at the
same time I also have to recognize that
I'm not a lot of people have the
blessing to be able to have this
understanding because it is a sort of a
spiritual practice to stay in this type
of thinking you know and our culture we
have a culture that's really rooted in
materialism individualism and just just
pure unadulterated nonsense you know as
selfishness so
it is a lot about the culture of like
the individual and rather than the
community and rather than how do you you
know help take care of the brothers
sisters around you and you did take care
of you as well this it's a huge
consciousness transition that's
happening and I'm really excited to just
be bright and like the middle of it in
so many ways yeah like right there in
the middle of it is especially with the
gen Z kids that are coming into life
that are you know that definitely think
this way yeah they're gonna be throwing
all of the old systems on their heads
especially with technology like
blockchain that enables them to do so
they can't believe all the generational
issues that have been going on for so
long and how they're finally being fixed
through technology yeah well I mean
technology can be also as you know
technology's a double-edged sword and
it's all how we use it and you know we
need to be proactive about showing that
generation see what a new society will
look like because they can't lead us
there if the folks who are before them
which is our generation don't get it
together right and right now our
generation is experiencing a lot it's
just basically compound interest of
generations of living in a messed-up
society right but I think we are really
like waking up there's like this huge
consciousness transformation and we're
looking at like how do we actually be
more community oriented which is what
blockchain is too it's like instead of
us going to like one central figure to
be able to do the things that we need to
do to live it is decentralized and it's
distributed meaning like we all have the
same amount of power we all have the
same ability to get on to the same
platform as anyone else and do the
things that we need to do so I say
blockchain technology not as just a way
to technically transform society but
also in that adaptive way to but we have
to be open to that so another thing is
I'm concerned about some of the
individuals who are considered leaders
in this blockchain space because like we
said this technology's going to change
everything in our society it's gonna hit
every single sector
and it's not just about the technology
it's about the individual are building
it which is like one of our values being
innovation right and when you have
individuals who haven't done that really
done that work in terms of like
developing core values learning how to
respect themselves and others the values
of coop cooperation and collaboration
we're just gonna get the same things
over and over again so it doesn't matter
we can throw a blockchain whatever issue
but it's the mind behind it
yes yes so this is a principle of of
moving of it's a the principle is
figuring out the principles it's
figuring out the values of the children
the youngest ages possible and ensuring
that we're moving forward in a direction
that is caring what Ron will pull up the
next it was the the addresses to support
the causes over there I have I do have
this you know page so social justice
focus rather than so there's something
that I think is an important topic to
ask about oh cool yeah this is good yeah
oh oh interesting yeah those move yeah
this is an insane image I actually have
this image on my slides as well where I
show the differences in wealth
inequality that one is an intense one
just seeing the dichotomy you can also
see that in Tijuana and San Diego mm-hmm
interesting so then this is equity right
yeah
yeah equal distribution resource and
opportunities within a system is rooted
in inequality social justice minded
individuals from various sectors come
year support the development of
blockchain project I serve the most
vulnerable every blockchain project
should be designed to uplift
marginalized communities and eliminate
the wealth gap poverty intergenerational
trauma and promote true democracy with
unfair institutions cryptocurrency is a
tool of economic sovereignty in order to
make it make use of it as such efforts
must be made to reclaim its purpose yep
ok so let's take let's take this because
I think this is an important point and
there's gonna be some viewership is
going to be interested in in hearing
kind of like how this works you know
there's also going to be a lot of people
I think within our within our community
did down you know aren't interested and
everything that Daisy is talking about
there's a resistance to that yeah we
started unpacking that a little a little
you know mortgage Daisy it also
mentioned the design there aren't she's
concerned with where some people are
taking the concept of blockchain to so I
yeah I'm like I want to will she talk
about she brought up something really
important which was just that if the
technology that's being made is being
made with values of inequality then it
doesn't [ __ ] matter what technology
you make and what you throw at it it's
got to be made with values that are
transcendent of inequality and so ok so
here's here's the question I think
people will appreciate this question
being addressed by you is that is the
it's like the the proper the proper way
of addressing the generational poverty
what is the proper way of addressing the
generational poverty
community initiatives that's all crazy
there's not one right answer there's not
one right way there needs to be a
multitude of initiatives to tackle the
root cause of generational inequality
and generational poverty so all those
different like phenomena that created
that I talked about earlier it needs to
happen from there so I would guess it
needs to start from the level of the
individual we need to really really do
the work in terms of understanding that
first role we're all interconnected so
if I'm suffering that individuals
suffering so eventually I'm gonna
probably be in their position so I
should probably care and try to help one
too is on the interpersonal level like
how we're treating each other and how we
view each other if you come into my
office looking for a job and I have all
these different like social like biases
and like beams running within my
consciousness that are poisoning my mind
I I'm gonna be less likely to want to
give you that opportunity because of
whatever is happening in here second is
on the community level how do we set up
infrastructure and community to help us
handle these processes on the individual
and interpersonal level to help us learn
how to work together to develop our own
economic systems right so that we can
become self sovereign and independent
from the mainstream institutions and
then on the institutional level how do
we hold institutional's institutions and
how can we help them hold themselves
accountable for the harm that they've
caused for some of the things that we've
seen happen for some of the initiatives
that we've seen them support for the
ways in which they've mismanaged funds
right and on the policy level how are we
crafting policy and regulation and
compliance right that can allow for what
I discussed on the individual
interpersonal community and
institutional level that's how it needs
to flow not from the top down but from
the bottom up and it could be vice versa
too depending on what issue you're
dealing with right so when we're talking
about like for instance this issue of
like income inequality we can definitely
pull it and make sure that we pass
policies and make sure people get paid
the same and on the individual level we
can make sure folks get proper like
Career Training right yeah I see how
that works
yeah from your like how you initially
you know brought up all those different
solutions because that is how it is it's
a multi-faceted issue that can be
addressed in many of the different ways
including top-down/bottom-up now okay
here's another question I'd probably be
that the following would probably be
interested in hearing how does how does
one in a position of being underserved
or underrepresented how do they maximize
their potential through their individual
abilities wow this is a good question
and this is actually like the issue too
because generational poverty comes with
generational trauma and generational
trauma comes with low self-esteem
emotional dysregulation lack of ability
to see into the future helplessness and
hopelessness coping mechanisms that are
dysfunctional the whole nine right so in
order for us to tell in it for an order
for an individual experiencing
generational poverty to want to be able
to get out of it and and help themselves
first we have to actually help them
understand what happened to them and see
that it's actually not your individual
fault or not the fall of your family or
community this is something systemic and
this is something that has been going on
right that's a form of empowerment cuz
then it open their eyes like oh wow okay
I see now this is just like a machine
that's doing this it's not my individual
issues not my own family's individual
issue on my race or my gender it's
individual issue right and then you have
to basically be able to motivate that
individual you have to expose them to
new opportunities new people new spaces
help them develop new neural pathways
new ways of thinking being and doing or
else you can throw all kinds
opportunities at them and nothing's
gonna stick and I have first-hand
experience with this because I am I do
work with like homeless youth
disconnected families disconnected youth
and
there's a lot of self-defeat because of
the generational trauma and they have
seen nothing but their family members
dying going to jail being on drugs
homeless whatever so they already it's
basically um they start to have
something where it's a manifest destiny
they they're like that's gonna be my
path so why do any of this anyways right
and then they start to basically
facilitate their own destruction and
their own demise so that's why I won't
focus are like well you know they have
all these nonprofits they have welfare
did it how come they just can't make
themselves better it's because you're
not even looking at we're talking my
people who've been in the same situation
their family's been in the same cycle
for hundreds of years
right the machine machine it's a system
that is designed to keep that going
right you just can't come to one day be
like oh you can do a B C and D they're
gonna be like you're trying to scam me
cuz there's also that level of distress
too you know like are they trying to
scare me I don't believe you what do you
want to get out of me that's why I
relationship building a community
building is so important right in order
to help those individuals see what they
can be a mentorship is important yeah
and then being able to see people who
look just like them in these positions
like even me the things that I'm doing I
don't consider myself like I'll be on
say a blockchain or like some famous
person but I know that there are people
now who are looking up to me you know in
order to make things happen I'm looking
up to me as like a mentor looking up to
me as a role model so of course oh yeah
yeah I conduct myself a certain way and
at the same time - I have those people
in my world you know who help me see the
best of myself you know so I think
that's it and that's why with blotching
for social justice when we're talking
about how we do the economic health
fairs we have to talk about social
justice we have to talk about inequities
- so people understand that there's a
system put in place for you to not get
opportunities it's not you not doing
enough it's not you being lazy there's a
stack of hurdles and barriers set up for
you to be able to not get yeah right so
that was exactly the answer that I think
needed to be
yeah that was really well said Daisy
that was really really well said you say
lots of great things Daisy and I'm glad
that people have someone like you to
look up to yeah and and I think you're
you know you're saying it in a way that
just enables people of all walks to
understand because when you are given a
good roll of the dice a better roll of
the dice than someone else's it can be
tough to empathize and respect the one
that has a less fortunate roll of the
dice and so I think that the way that I
ask the question and then the way you
answered it was a really good way to
inspire people to care about the lower
rolls of the dice that's why I asked it
because there's so many people that
watch this that need that answer to care
more about it to make it more relatable
to them to make it more visceral for
their emotional state to care more okay
so this was really important what you
said they were this was so so good when
you were talking about the Machine and
all of the systemic issues that young
kids face when they're born you know we
have this dichotomy here on market and
sixth Street where it's 100k plus a year
engineers and laying and they're walking
next to homeless people and then you
know we've had a couple conversations
with some of the homeless people on the
streets and they don't even like being
called homeless they just say I'm
choosing not to have a permanent
residence that's what they say and then
furthermore is there like you'll both of
my mom and dad were meth heads you know
one of them was like my dad went to jail
when I was a tiny kid you know this and
then he just got out of the guy just got
out of jail so anyway these are literal
stories thank you for the timer on I
feel like we're gonna go a little bit a
little bit over but but these are these
are sort of the the stories of the
variables of the Machine that we don't
actually get to see and feel and become
part of us you know just
you just kind of like you know move it
off the side and brush it off it's
something I do with me I don't want to
touch that all these dirty people uh
these poor people why are they acting
like that
they're so uncivilized right because
when you humanize other people you
dehumanize yourself right so it's easy
for you to look at these people
look at these certain communities and
have all these judgments and disrespect
and assumptions right but it's harder to
get out of your fancy car get out of
your office right go talk to those
individuals go spend a day in their
community it's harder to go actually
read their history and study this system
of inequality and of oppression because
it doesn't matter to you because at the
end of the day you're not impacted right
so all these crypto fools they're making
all a bunch of their money and you don't
even realize that basically you're at
the head of the next financial
revolution right the first this is the
second largest transfer of wealth in
history the first one was a slave trade
and you're at the forefront of this and
I studied to be like hmm I see this
presidency I see all these things
happening
I see Silicon Valley I see the income
the homelessness and inequality let me
use the extra funds that I have now cuz
I'm printing money out of thin air to
help some of these social issues instead
it's let me go buy a Ferrari or hire a
hundred strippers for my party so it's a
lot of like I said Alan and you are
someone who I have a lot of respect for
because you do your work right because
it's not easy to recognize how we've
played into these different systems of
oppression and these are in mine states
and it's not easy to address your own
privilege even when you have been harmed
right even when you come from a
background in a family that has not
experienced the best of the best you
know it's not easy to do that but we
still do it anyways because we know on
the other side is we get to be light
hearted we get to be have empathy for
other people we get to do to connect
with people on a deeper level we get to
create very rare experiences with people
that we probably would have not had had
we had our blinders on and we're just
worried about being elitist and in our
bubbles and whatnot you know so there's
a lot of work that needs to be done in
the space and that's why I like every
single blockchain
a conference needs to have a panel about
social impact I'm centering it yeah yeah
yeah that's good I'd like that one right
yeah that's because I've been to so many
as well and that would be amazing if
there was a social impact oriented panel
or or even just as a theme in general
that's what you're that's what you do
that's why you do it to share that
message more so man so many ways to go
with this and I want to talk more about
like you know the actual events and the
curriculum but it's just like I'm still
being pulled for you to just keep
dropping this these really relatable
ways of understanding so let me let me
let me try and pull a bit more and see
what we can get from from it within the
machine that is systematically causing a
lot of the issues that we see in lower
socioeconomic again rolls of the dice
based on complete luck where you were
born and what does it code to what
whether your parents were in jail or
addicted to meth or whether they had
under came your jobs etc mm-hmm that
then it's about really getting that all
those variables exist and like you said
not having a narrow elitist mindset
about it but rather being like hey I
want to objectively see how things are
and you gave a really good example it's
you know spend one day out of the office
and literally going down the streets and
just doing your best to just stop and
just have a conversation or two or three
about you know what's up in your life
like are you like tell me about you you
know because then you'll actually learn
about and you'd be surprised at how many
people that we've talked to on the
streets artists philosophers musicians
creators of all different sorts this is
their really this is this is
just like you and me you know in many
ways this is in many ways just like you
and me and so they are you and me
you know but I would like to actually
you know Alan I think another thing too
that we don't actually explore a lot of
the times is folks are desensitized you
know I'm saying like completely
desensitized they're coming from
generations of being wealthy not having
a care having full access for privilege
you know um being able to do the things
that they want and move freely through
society and we're talking about
desensitization with the media they've
been watching certain themes and
stereotypes be embedded into their mind
year after year she'll have to show a
movie after movie
we're desensitized I go in the morning
and there's like a 20-foot line outside
a Starbucks right we're completely
desensitized this society promotes the
de synthesize a ssin going it
entertained right go and numb yourself
don't worry about other people you live
in a bubble so for a lot of folks when
we have these type of conversations they
can't even like kick it like this they
can't relate because they are
desensitized on a deeper level than we
may actually really realize right so
it's like me trying to pour a gallon
into a cup like this it's gonna overflow
they're gonna start it's good they're
gonna start tapping out they're gonna
start getting angry they're gonna start
going into cognitive dissonance right or
they start arguing and throwing out all
kinds of like nonsense and rubbish like
trying to contradict what you're saying
even though they're contradicting
themselves they're gonna see all kinds
of very strange irate agitated and
childish behavior because we're also you
have to also understand that empathy is
something of the nervous system it's not
a thought it's something that you
actually have to have the capacity to do
and there's a bunch of research studies
on empathy and empathy neurons and how
those become desensitized right you can
desensitize your your empathy neurons
with substances you can do it through at
work and at different addictions you can
even do it through
not having gone through certain
experiences right because going through
certain experiences opens you up to be
able to help you become stronger and
develop resilience or they can help you
come close and become calcified and
hardened and that those blinders on to
the world so a lot of people in the
blockchain space just in this society in
general that's what they're dealing with
soma blockchain for social justice it's
more than just like hey we got to get in
poor communities into a Black team and
crypto it's really more about like you
need to start transforming your mind
about our how our society functions in
general right and it's gonna actually
help you develop a better use case -
yeah I'm writing a book about this I'm
on chapter 7 I like the term even before
this I've been colouring about this and
everyone was like yeah it's time to have
conversations with your family I was
like you're wasting more time you're
beating a dead horse because you see it
you see it with your own eyes you just
choose not to do anything about it it's
a choice that's something that we have
to really really understand it's a
choice and even me would be in my own
self care process in my life journey I
got to realize certain some of the
certain things I do it's a choice now am
i aware that it's a choice in the moment
I may not be I may just be conditioned
like that but once I become aware of it
I have to then make those changes I have
to take accountability for the choices
that I made and there's no neutral side
I feel like a lot of people try to be
neutral
there's no neutral side on the play
devil's advocate there's no such thing
as diplomacy we're talking about
systemic oppression
you're either promoting it and a part of
it we're not saying anything and still
promoting it and a part of it or you are
actively trying to dismantle it yeah you
have to pick a side and this situation
that we're going through just globally
globally is going to catechol people
into you have to pick a side now so
blockchain crypto folks they're gonna
pick a side do you want to stay with the
foolishness or do you want to join this
new team where we're creating projects
and ecosystems and communities that are
we really care about each other like
starfish mission yeah you care about
each other we take care of each other
you
no I really love those folks down there
like black chain we take care of each
other blockchain for social justice we
take care of each other you know we make
sure that we get different opportunities
that we stack these different
conferences that we're doing what we
need to do to make sure that the
community has at the end of the day
damn I rarely ever allow people to be
binary on the show but that's a pretty
good like we were all nuanced driven on
the show and and but and that's a really
good but that's a pretty good case for
binaries even the people in the middle
that are not doing anything about it are
still on the side of enabling the
systemic oppression to continue going on
and and then the people that are arguing
on like a devil's advocate perspective
in many ways are doing it from a from a
point of like quit whining about
systemic oppression and go and just
bring yourself fully into the world but
then the arguments that is like yo the
machines all the variables of the
machine are there to hold that back so
you have to change the variables in the
machine to really enable people to be
their fullest in the world and so that's
my whole conversation over the last
[ __ ] like eight months on this topic
since I've you know featured Jordan
Peterson and they've been talking about
some of the intellectual dark web stuff
and then also I've had a really good
amount of time of really being in the
middle of helping out with homeless and
San Francisco over the last five years
I've lived here really being just in
touch more with being globalist in many
ways and being pro helping socioeconomic
lower roll of the dice and so that's
what's really given me this newest idea
of it and you just made it very clear it
is a sort of it is sort of a binary
point that that either we're gonna allow
the systemic oppression to continue or
we're gonna enable the lower rolls of
the dice to really fly out with their
full wings and potential can I add to
that piece yeah where people be like you
know why we're all in the same boat now
you know why are you complaining about
this
let's just get to work or just shut up
and start talking water it's irrelevant
why are you bringing identity politics
into technology did it and what that is
it's called bypass that's called bypass
that's called suppression and that's
called derailment and remember I said
you can't pour down into because they
actually don't have a complex worldview
they don't have a complex perspective so
they're very narrow-minded and really
like narrow thinking so when you try to
start talking about these different
things they get super uncomfortable and
they try to bring it back to something
that makes them comfortable which is not
talking about it at all
but the challenge here is we need to
really start challenging ourselves to
move out of that and I also know a lot
of folks who you know they go to Burning
Man baby these are your logical journeys
they blow their mind in their oral part
with psychedelics traveling in the
Amazon going to perpetrate and
surveillance indigenous communities to
see how they live or whatever there is
consequences for all of that behavior
and I feel like a lot of those folks who
are in that space and who are doing that
they are also I would say they don't
have no grounding they don't have no
reality they're not rooted in reality
and in many ways they've just fallen
into a new trap right into the whole
elevate your consciousness trap and that
new a jury you have to understand that
yeah that world exists and this material
world still exists all you need to learn
how to walk between both worlds
yeah at all points in time a good way to
put it and those a lot of those people
are also in the blockchain crypto space
and their leaders and they go when they
drop acid and be like oh we're all wine
and we're all equal sorry no that's not
how what's going down and still live in
a matrix right we still live in a in a
artificial stimulated reality where
there are certain mechanisms put in
place to harness the energy right and my
force of other people so while you are
delving and dabbling into all those
things recognize that that exists too
you know so that's all I really have to
say about that and there's a lot that I
could talk about
but I don't want to seem like a Negative
Nancy because I don't know you're not
you're not you're realistic really yeah
you're so grounded in the real realness
the reality yeah yeah cuz okay this this
example is really important you know you
you you were bringing up a lot of the
New Age consciousness drive which is
really important but if it gets so
disconnected from the reality of what
you're describing is literally the life
force out of people being sucked by the
machine it's really important way to put
it and we talked about that quite a bit
and I'm glad that you have a very strong
personality around it Rob you're a
beautiful person so strong and smart and
you say I just feel like I'm a voice box
for the people people don't feel this
they know this but because of the shame
right and the consequences and all the
other kind of stuff like the ability to
hold a gallon of water right that's a
because you can mold a new cup you can
expand the amount of water you can hold
but it requires a lot of work a lot of
work a lot of really looking at oneself
in the mirror and being like wow I
didn't have generational poverty like
really just [ __ ] admit that like you
just didn't have it over that at least
the last whatever four generations or
however long that's been and then look
at someone that did have it and yeah
yeah all these variables of the actual
matrix that and you know Tim Draper I
don't really I don't agree with his
politics at all and now whole family its
whatever but he wrote a book and I have
that book and I the first page that I
opened to was make amends for all of
your transgressions whoa whoa make
amends for all of your transgressions
right whether whether cautious of them
or not now and then the explanation was
we've all done things were benefited
from the
I harm other people or we've all made
mistakes etc etc yeah there's nothing
wrong with being able to look at that
look about how we benefited look how
we've harmed other people and making
amends for that yeah yeah
simple absolutely that same concept to
this right here and I was like wool mr.
Draper like you may have like [ __ ] up
politics but that was brilliant right so
I encourage everyone to go read that
book
damn just as you know we are completely
fan funded by patreon something that's
just something like that I think you
have like you got a skill here with this
even just the way that your cuz I've
done many interviews all kinds of people
and the questions you ask I'm I'm the
way you just like even our boys it's
like very radial like you know so just
keep going whatever you do I like this
show thanks Daisy yeah thank you thank
you so much and you have a really
[ __ ] good skill - I'm really liking
yours yeah yeah I want to hear you speak
I hope to get that tech inclusion gig I
think I'm working on yeah I'm gonna try
that yeah this is the problem is that
you go to events like Ted or whatever
the blockchain events right not be fresh
Jade but you go there and the problem is
it's a monologue it's a one directional
it's coming from my mind I've crafted
this message for you and that's fine
that's like the Ted model is fine in
that sense and it works in a certain way
but if you just put another person that
has been doing thousands of interviews
let's say throughout their life and that
has a pretty good breadth across
subjects and a pretty good emotional
intelligence as well and you sit them
down next to them and you unpack your
mind and your soul in your heart on a
show with that person it can lead to new
ways of understanding reality that can
then kind of drive people in you know
there's a [ __ ] bell curve there's a
probability curve and there's a lot of
people that will never they'll never be
able to have a gallon glass and then
there are people that definitely already
have a gallon glass and then there's the
people in the middle of the bell curve
that have some
between the two and so the point is to
find the people on the upper half of the
bell curve that have a pretty big glass
that are just about ready to have the
whole gallon in there like hopefully
myself and just to be able to drag me
more into the side of having a wider
glass and so that's what we do and the
best
I personally think the best way to drag
more people over on that upper half of
the bell curve is by doing things like
sitting down here and talking about it
to diverse audience versus when you just
go and have a monologue people they
don't see any contrarian perspective
even in the slightest and then it's like
why would I believe one like the one
thing the one person the one you know
versus an actual conversation right came
to life when you stroked his ego he just
went off on his little team all right
maybe I'm out of line now I stand
corrected but he just came to life a
little bit there I think I've been
working we've been on yeah I'm glad that
I'm glad that you also feel some of the
benefits of an interlocutor that can
have this is this is nobody has a
conversation how many people in the
universe are talking about oh what's the
difference between a monologue and
having an interlocutor at a dialogue
onstage almost nobody in the world's
talking about that right now and so the
point is if we but how many people are
having monologues on stages right now
99% of all stage presences are either
monologues or panels you know not
dialogue between two people on a very
tough subject this is a tough subject
it's not an easy subject to talk about
the variables that the matrix and how
they're affecting people's lives and
suppressing people from achieving their
full potential folks don't get it yeah
this is deep I think that this is like
the deepest understanding that any of us
should have is how its operating and why
it's operating and who it's impacting I
think
and you have to understand your enemy
you have to and in my training my social
justice training and in the study of my
my heroes I guess the ancestors that I
emulate either be wells Sojourner Truth
Harriet Tubman Michael Malcolm X Marcus
Garvey they all studied the minds of the
people who were causing them havoc in
hell in order to navigate out of those
systems so why would we do the same and
do it properly yeah yeah yeah fine
find the variables that are causing the
control systems of the matrix and then
fight against those yeah the consumption
the consumption of the variables is
normal or what are you yeah actually not
only that consumption I have I think
it's the consumption of the variables as
normal but also the engagement in these
variables as normal that's like I'm just
doing my job
right ah yeah yet that you called it
like it was like I like bypassing the
bypass yeah I mean like you were either
consuming or being consumed but in what
way is how right so god is so much of
the whole equity thing got [ __ ] by
communism and socialism as well that
that that because because there's so
much negative connotation with that then
it got but you know I do want to say
this there's a really good book and it's
called the great cosmic mother it's like
this fact it's amazing amazing writing
and the great cosmic mother oh yes Gaia
yes so and it also has a chapter about
marks and ankle you know angle was
Marx's right hand and people don't know
this but Marx got his theory of like
communism socialism what not by actually
studying ancient market matriarchal
economic systems and societies hmm but
thinking about this is that what they
left out was the existential development
being centered around trade community
development all of that they even put
that in there that's why we keep on
having iterations of socialism and
communism that end up in a pile of
people being dead right and people in a
pile of dead bodies right because they
took out that existential piece so that
book is very powerful it really goes
into very much detail in terms of how
those ancient systems operated and how
they are very similar to those two
systems that we didn't mention but what
piece is missing right so there's work
to do
I first see a future where it'll be
hilarious to look back at this and be
like wow we let that oppressive [ __ ]
happen for that long and it'll be
interesting because we'll have so much
technological progress by that point in
terms of you having things that doesn't
preclude me from having things AI in
nanotech everywhere Washington ergy
everywhere that it'll be funny when we
look back and we go wow we were fighting
for resources we'll have so much
abundance but it takes a fuckload of
work and mapping to actually get to that
place of straight abundance and
prosperity for everyone and I really
believe in us
getting there and even having that on
Mars and having that on other celestial
bodies yeah I don't know if we're ready
for that we have to figure this one out
first that's what I'm saying cuz we're
gonna just go there and we're gonna find
some beings who already know about
planetary Rover is there that we haven't
figured that out yet that's funny that
leads us into like the questions that we
asked at the end of the show I feel like
maybe we should plug some of the you
know I met you at when did we first meet
oh yeah at the event at the vault
so we met there like a month before
boxing for social justice so it's like
May or something when we met and then we
have a whole playlist now it's the
simulation plus boxing for social
justice playlist on on our channel so
you can go you can go watch all the
videos with you know Mackenzie slaughter
and Cheryl Davis and you know Ferris
away so we have all those videos that
are on our channel you guys can go watch
them and so yeah we're excited to go and
you know do another future one soon
so okay so that event happened that was
a really powerful event now you have
events and you have the curriculum so
the events happen what every couple of
months you have a blocking Frizzles
justice event at least once a month
oh yes and you're bringing the social
justice aspect of what blockchain can do
to that event to that event and I'm also
bringing that community to that event
yes be able to network and all that
other good stuff too
yep yep and then what does what is the
curriculum
what like the curriculum is onboarding
people to become blockchain developers
boarding people to be on crypto
investors and so what is the curriculum
kind of like look you know what does it
look like because you know here's you
know this is awesome we got your support
I'm so happy we just got crypto support
as hot soon we'll have we'll have we'll
have this link also in the bio but yeah
hit us with the curriculum that's being
developed we're working right now with a
couple community partners to develop a
blockchain curriculum there's gonna be
open source for all of the programs that
help young people become developers so
what will take them from like if you
have any type of job skills it'll help
you improve those skills and then also
help you learn how to be like a
blockchain developer so that's actually
what we're working on right now and then
another curriculum that we're working on
this we already have this we're just
revamping it um how did like invest so
just the intro to blockchain and crypto
white papers wallets token economics all
that and then another thing that we have
that we're already doing is a curriculum
actually how to build your own
blockchain because being a developer
yeah that's awesome and it's amazing and
it's cool but it's what you design on
top of the blockchain that makes it
worthwhile yeah and out of the
curriculum are they available on be
fresh Jade com
not yet okay so okay so maybe soon yeah
and it's gonna be a completely different
process in the way we administer that
like you're gonna have to like of course
I register with us yeah I'm to be one of
our community partners
come to the initial training to get you
ready to train that whole thing cool
okay so right now basically the
curriculum is being brought to locations
on site okay
and happening at the events I'm sorry
okay
Wow okay let's do it so you were talking
about let's do our ending questions now
so you were you were you you mentioned
HUD just a moment ago that we'll get to
Mars and we'll realize there are other
people there this is a question that we
asked on the show do you think we're
alone in the cosmos no and to think that
we are that's like arrogant and childish
how many galaxies do we have I was
looking at this like info graph of the
different galaxies and how like NASA
category and I was just like holy
freaking moly there's probably like ten
of me somewhere there there has to be
other planets because that is the only
way to really explain some of the [ __ ]
that we see on planet earth there's got
to be something else going on though I
love thinking about how other
civilizations have evolved on their
rocks orbiting stars because how many of
them also are dealing with the same
stupid issues that we are how many of
them have transcended those issues yeah
yeah and what does that look like when
they do etc so okay do you think we're
in a simulation let's see let me answer
this properly because you know people
that look like me in the past when we
talk like this we become
institutionalized so yeah that's [ __ ]
we got to change that yeah but you know
again that's the threat to the system
because if you start telling the truth
they'll be like they're gonna just try
to make you crazy which is what they're
gonna do to on musk in a minute well I
would say I just know that the dream
world has been very real for me too and
I get premonitions in that world as well
so do we live in a simulation we
probably do because if we think that
this is real life where you are born
just to spend
you're the first like eighteen years of
your life in a cage
having your wings clip and your mind
molded and shaped to become a worker for
the next forty some odd years just so
you can get a little bit of amount of
money to go on a couple vacations and
die you got to be [ __ ] kidding me
this is a joke and I'm not buying it
like this is not reality it's absolutely
not
but you know this material world is very
dense in 3d right and the more that we
engage in that dense and 3d Ennis the
less that we can tap out of the
simulation right so that's why it's
really important that's why a lot of
people are going to do the ayahuasca and
doing all those type of things you know
because um they don't actually have a
way to do that without the stimulation
right in the simulation so meditate get
an altar talk to your ancestors get some
crystals go in the water change your
diet really become light as a feather so
that's all I really have to say about
that
yeah I like I like I said the clothes
look the more we transcend the
three-dimensional material reality the
more that we get we tap into what is
true which is like how is this 3d world
true there's so much control systems
here that are limited limiting but we're
also blessed with some of that plant
medicine and all this other kind of
stuff on the planet which is great the
ability to meditate you know to eat
light and stuff like that that's a
really good Daisy really good yeah
can you quickly mention why you think
they're about to point at Elon and say
that he's crazy and yeah because he
exposed them um how did he expose them
okay yeah well I'm just gonna repeat
what he said okay and I was watching
that interview and you can tell that he
has fought really hard to not I will say
become hijacked
in a way oh by that the entities that be
uh-huh because they hijack they know who
they want to continue to do their
bidding and do their work right yeah
like maybe like the fossil fuel industry
the Koch brothers Jeff Bezos all of them
babe they've already pesos hijacked of
course every ways you have to be to
really think that what you're doing is
okay anyways
wait wait wait wait wait that's a huge
one though I'm glad you came here
because I yeah thank you most of the
politicians and businessmen they are how
is Bezos hijacked but musk isn't
hijacked because musk is the only one
that can do you not see the tools that
Amazon is creating and just putting out
there what do you mean I'm creating all
types of like retro facial recognition
for policing they're creating all kinds
of technology to hurt harm people they
pay their workers like dirt cheap trash
and wages and think about it's okay and
they're like oh trying to run and go
into space and you want musk in them is
doing that too but at the same time you
have business here on earth that you
need to take care of and just completely
like not even like we're more school
just complete impunity about it as well
but what I like what I know about you on
it and the fact that he's like basically
he's been really teetering is I've been
seeing just before that interview that
he did I've been seeing a lot of
articles about like how he's sleeping on
the floor like the Tesla you know
Factory
about how this is going on them about
how it was going on he's trying to
retain his humanist - yeah but I think
what's gonna end up happening is because
he basically like exposed the fact that
he and another tech company they're
trying to get Fatima Facebook Amazon
Google Microsoft Apple they're like a
conglomerate they're trying to get them
to sign like a pact in terms of these
are the parameters around how we would
use AI nothing more nothing less
and we agree and he basically exposed
that there but they're trying to do that
pact so now the Department of Justice is
on his head for some of the stuff that
he released in that video given the fact
that he was high yeah he was high but I
know that that man has more sense than
people may realize and I think that he
is he was really talking about the
dangers of AI and how some of these
companies are set to use those two
routes so what's gonna end up eventually
happening is the more that state
regulators start looking at hey the
federal government is not gonna do
anything we're gonna take this on
they're gonna just try to basically make
it seem like he's crazy to discredit his
statements but the thing is
it's already out of the bag so if they
do try to take him down he will be like
maybe the last one that they are sick
there they're able to take down because
the side he's watching I think that this
has happened so many times before that
people are ready hip
they already know we know what goes on
we know what 9/11 was an inside job we
know what's going on in this society and
how they magnify the fine area on that
one I my I'll just say this the United
States government does not have its
citizens at best interest I just know
that what happened after those series of
events that happen in New York to the
twin towers the only people that benefit
was the United States and some really
rich Investor's
I'm just looking at who benefited and
how they are benefiting that's it right
I would also like to add that there's
something going on right now as we speak
called the constitutional convention and
people are not even looking at this and
basically what they're trying to do is
they're trying to eliminate the
Constitution of the United States so
that each they can then create their own
Constitution or basically become a
republic has anybody watch Handmaid's
Tale okay wait this is happening now
wait there's they already have state
rights why do we want to abolish the
United States Constitution they already
have 28 out of the 34 states necessary
so that whole we want to split
California into three states yeah that
would have added two more red state
senators and governors to be able to say
yes people are not looking at policy
because I'm not looking at the long game
they're just looking at like the sort of
food shelter safety I mean the basic you
can't blame them
can't blame yeah it's really hard to
have time to critically think about
trillions of variables that go into a
game sometimes it's not even trillion
they actually all like I say the way I
categorize these things are all into
like overarching themes and there's only
like six of them and then those six
bases collapse into one and it's
scarcity like sociopaths II and
a psychotic behavior so it's not that
hard people try to make it too complex
and writing all these damn books stop
it's it's really it's not hard to
understand but I guess maybe I would
just say I was given a gift of I was I'm
also I've been here before so I'm like
this is all craziness we got it this
time that I'm here I'm like we got to
get it right this time
that's what I feel highness I don't even
feel I'm worthy to be in the same room
I'm not going back here okay oh my god
okay that was a great answer to
simulation and musk I have a lot
unpacking and learned though can I ask
the last question before we go yeah
broaden you math laughs Daisy what's the
most beautiful thing in the world the
most beautiful thing in the world is the
smile that you get from a little baby
across the bus can you make eye contact
they start making like little googly
eyes or little faces and for a minute
you don't think about systemic
oppression you don't think about bills
you don't think about anything you just
think about how innocent and pure that
child is and how you were able to put a
smile on their face with your little
antics and another beautiful thing is
I'm in a Facebook group for fat cats so
people just post pictures of their
fat-ass cats all day and this like the
cutest thing ever so anyways do not go
on there hi and everyone talks on baby
talk on the pictures and like these
grown-ass people talking baby talk on
these cat pictures whatever it takes the
the the child the innocence and that the
precious soul that's being analyzing and
having all the variables on it what's
mean what's like the one piece
advice if you could come up with one for
the parents that are molding their
children into the world please do not
hit your children please love your
children speak kindly to them because it
does impact them on levels that we are
not even able to understand and let them
be themselves introduce them to new
things yeah Wow Daisy what a great
freaking show thank you thank you so
much for joining us one more time so I
can get them I'm glad you had a good
time we had a great time in it I'm
really excited I'm really excited you
give me lots of hope and you give me you
do you give me lots of hope and and also
you give me a stronger you know roadmap
for you know for what I also care about
and in my attention to be focused on as
well
Meechum yeah much love everyone thank
you so much for tuning in if you guys
have thoughts comment below we'd love to
hear from you give us the good give us
the bad give us your thoughts cross at
all we'd love to hear from you joining
the community join the conversation also
going create go and build go build our
future go and make blogs make videos
make images make infographics make
businesses make all this music make all
this cool stuff art going create create
create think you're on a
producer-director much love much love to
you guys for tuning in and go check out
be for SJ calm thank you very much
everyone